♪ ♪
>> Tucker: YESTERDAY HBO
PULLED "GONE WITH THE WIND" FROM
ITS LINEUP OF MOVIES.
NOW FORBIDDEN.
IN DALLAS, THE CITY GOVERNMENT
REMOVED A STATUE OF THE TEXAS
RANGER.
MEANWHILE, NPR, NATIONAL PUBLIC
RADIO WOULD YOU PAY FOR BRIEFLY
PROMOTED A PIECE URGING READERS
TO "DECOLONIZE THEIR
BOOKSHELVES."
SO HERE WE HAVE CENSORING
MOVIES, RIPPING DOWN STATUES,
ENCOURAGING BOOK BURNING, WHAT
IS IT UP TO DO WITH POLICE
BRUTALITY?
NOTHING, THESE ARE ATTACKS ON
OUR SHARED HISTORY AND OUR
CULTURE.
THIS IS A TOPIC WORTH DISCUSSING
ON THEIR SMALL NO ONE WORTH
DISCUSSING IT MORE WIDTH THAN
THE GREAT MARK STEYN.
MARK STEYN, WOULD YOU MIND
HOLDING UP TODAY’S NEWSPAPER TO
ESTABLISH THAT IT IS IN FACT YOU
AND NOT A HOLOGRAM?
>> I LOVE TO HOLD UP TODAY’S
NEWSPAPER BUT IT WENT OUT OF
BUSINESS SIX WEEKS INTO THE
PANDEMIC WHEN THEY QUARANTINED
ALL THE NEWSPAPER BOYS BECAUSE
THE BEST WAY TO GET COVID IS BY
THROWING THE INFECTED NEWSPAPER
ON TO YOUR NEIGHBOR’S DOORSTEP
SO THAT’S ALL OVER, TALKER,
YOU’VE GOT TO KEEP UP.
>> Tucker: WE’VE MISSED YOU.
YOU’RE WATCHING ALL OF US FROM
SECLUSION, NONE OF THIS SEEMS TO
HAVE ANYTHING TO DO WITH POLICE
BRUTALITY.
WHAT’S GOING ON?
>> TO GO TO WHAT WE’VE BEEN
TALKING ABOUT TONIGHT AND LAST
NIGHT, WHERE OTHER PEOPLE WHO
WILL DEFEND THIS?
YOU CAN’T HAVE A CULTURE WAR IF
ONE SIDE REFUSES TO TURN UP, THE
POLITICS ON THE LOOTING, THE
RIOTING, THE REPUBLICAN PARTY
AND CONSERVATIVES HAVE BEEN
LARGELY SILENT AND SIMILARLY ON
THE CULTURE WAR THEY -- THE
OTHER SIDE HAS BEEN LARGELY
SILENT.
IT’S NOT THE YOUNG SNOWFLAKE
GENERATION WHO ARE EASILY
TRIGGERED, IT’S THE MIDDLE-AGED
GUYS RUNNING HBO AND THESE OTHER
CORPORATIONS, WHY ARE THEY NOT
DEFENDING THIS?
THEY’VE MADE MILLIONS OFF OF
"GONE WITH THE WIND."
IF PEOPLE DON’T LIKE IT, FINE.
MAKE YOUR OWN MOVIE, WRITE YOUR
OWN NOVEL, DO YOUR OWN PLAY
ABOUT THE ANTEBELLUM SOUTH BUT
DON’T DEMAND THAT THINGS BE
ABOLISHED SIMPLY BECAUSE THEY
WEREN’T MADE WITH THE PECULIAR
NARCISSISTIC SENSIBILITIES OF
2020 IN MIND.
>> Tucker: SO OUR ENTIRE
CULTURE EXISTS DIGITALLY NOW,
IT’S VERY DIFFICULT TO GET RID
OF ALL COPIES OF "CATCHER IN THE
RYE."
IT’S VERY EASY TO ELIMINATE AN
E-BOOK, SHOULD BE WORRIED ABOUT
ERASING OUR CULTURE, OUR PAST,
OUR CIVILIZATION?
>> ABSOLUTELY.
YOU SAY DIGITALLY -- I’M NOT SO
SURE.
WE MAY BE AT THE BEGINNING OF
ONE OF THOSE DYSTOPIAN TALES
WHERE IN A FEW YEARS’ TIME,
SOMEBODY STUMBLES ACROSS THE
LAST VIDEOCASSETTE RECORDER IN
THE WOODS AND THAT HAPPENS TO BE
A TAPE OF "GONE WITH THE WIND"
AND THEY MARVEL AT IT BECAUSE
THEY’VE NEVER SEEN THIS BEFORE.
THIS GENERATION IS A HYPERTENSE
PER GENERATION AND UNFORTUNATELY
IT’S DETERMINED TO DESTROY
EVERYTHING IT DOESN’T UNDERSTAND
WHICH IS QUITE A LOT.
>> Tucker: I’VE GOT TO ASK YOU
ABOUT YOUR WHEREABOUTS, YOU SENT
WORD TO OUR STAFF THAT YOU ARE
IN A CAVE IN KANDAHAR BUT I
DON’T THINK HE REALLY WERE,
WHERE HAVE YOU BEEN?
>> YOU CAN GET A GREAT TAN IN A
CAVE IN KANDAHAR.
I DIDN’T QUALIFY FOR THE
EXECUTIVE BUT PROPERTY IS
INCREDIBLY REASONABLE.
YOU KNOW, LET’S BE HONEST, WHEN
THE POWDER KEG GOES UP, THE CAVE
IN KANDAHAR WILL BE LOOKING
PRETTY GOOD.
IF I COME BACK LAST MONTH I
WOULD’VE DONE LOCKDOWN SHTICK.
IF I’D COME BACK LAST WEEK I
WOULD’VE DONE LOOTING SHTICK BUT
I’M LOOKING FOR THAN EITHER OR
ABOUT BOX BECAUSE THE CHOICE
BETWEEN BEING LOCKED DOWN IN
EVERY ASPECT OF YOUR LIFE ARE
BEING ALLOWED A RUN OF THE
STREETS BECAUSE WHITE SUPREMACY
IS AN EVEN GREATER PUBLIC HEALTH
THRICE CRISIS THAN COVID, I’M
LOOKING FOR THEN EITHER OF THE
ABOVE BOX IN THOSE TWO CHOICES.
>> Tucker: I’M NOT SURPRISED
TO LEARN THAT UNLIKE THE REST OF
US YOU FIGURED OUT A BETTER WAY